[Applaudissements]
bonjour nous nous avons la chance de
vivre en démocratie nous pouvons parler
nous pouvons écrire pouvons agir et nous
pouvons nous engager
nous pouvons nous engager par réaction à
quelque chose contre quelque chose pour
quelque chose pour apporter un beau
projet là en ce moment moi ça me fait
bien plaisir de voir tous ces jeunes là
qu'ils se mobilisent pour défendre
l'environnement
lorsque j'avais 18 ans je travaillais
dans un petit hôpital de la région
j'étais agent hospitalier est en fait
aux dans nos activités d'agent trois
fois par jour il fallait aller dans la
cuisine de l'hôpital pour chercher les
repas et est donc j'étais dans un
service déjà de personnes âgées
on appelait ça gériatrie serpa donc été
disposés dans des marmites bien lourde
bien chaude et il fallait traverser la
cour avec s'étaient servis et c est le
matin il fallait aller chercher les
bidons de café et de l'est encore une
fois bien lourd et bien bouillant et pas
tout à fait hermétique
du coup on était un peu brûlé
quelquefois une fois le petit déjeuner
servi fallait nettoyer ranger et sait
mettre de côté du café et du lait pour
le servir après le repas du midi et il
en restait encore dans ces bidons et là
à léo ou rejeter tout dans l'évier tous
les jours et donc j'ai demandé aux
collègues mais pourquoi pourquoi on fait
comme ça au dessus et on a on a toujours
fait comme ça toujours
après je suis allé voir la cheffe du
service et j'ai dit est ce que vous
pourriez commandé un peu moins ne porte
ce serait moins lourd et puis elle m'a
répondu à temps ça fait huit ans que je
travaille ici huit ans que je commande
la même quantité tous les jours à
l'intendance ils vont se demander ce que
je sais ce que je fais là donc non ce
n'est pas possible
alors j'ai dit mais à ce moment là on
fait peut-être organiser un goûter
l'après midi et puis en plus ici les
résidences ennuis nous on s'ennuie donc
voilà ça serait une occasion de créer
quelque chose voilà de passer un bon
moment ensemble
attends tu t'ennuies l'après midi eh
bien tu va nettoyer toutes les portes du
couloir bon deux ou trois jours après je
je je reviens même proposition
même réponse à peu près tu t'ennuies tu
va nettoyer toutes les tables de nuit
intérieur et extérieur bon la situation
était bloquée
et puis finalement une de mes collègues
chantal médite un réseau il faut qu'on
trouve une solution est la solution
donc là il ya prescription mais on est
bien d'accord g on a caché le lait et le
café est là et l'après midi on a
organisé ce fameux goûter
et puis et puis on a recommencé deux
fois trois fois et finalement au bout
d'un mois
le goûter a été obligatoire tous les
jours dans le service et dans les autres
services de gériatrie
voilà
plusieurs années après je suis en poste
chez un poste de responsable d'une
petite maison de retraite toujours dans
la région ou petites maisons de retraite
28 résidents une petite équipe des
petits moyens avec une direction
aussi voilà non ce n'est pas possible
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
avec ses petits moyens là on a
transformé cette maison de retraite en
un lieu de vie incroyable c'est à dire
que l'on sait on fait on s'est fixé
l'objectif de faire un projet de vie
pour tous où chacun avait la parole
les résidents avaient la parole les
familles les amis les voisins
l'équipe de jour et de nuit tout le
monde avait son mot à dire et on a
construit des projets ensemble et on
s'est ouvert sur l'extérieur et
l'extérieur venaient chez nous on a
travaillé on a monté des projets avec
les associations de la commune avec la
bibliothèque avec les écoles avec les
collèges et les lycées de la région
on a créé des liens
partout et des liens à l'intérieur les
résidents je répète avait la parole et
en particulier une bénévole qui
s'appelait marie thé et venez aider
faisait parler et même ceux qui depuis
longtemps ne parlait plus avait des
choses à dire et elle écrivait mot pour
mot ce qu'il disait et les leur
redonnait et puis
un jour rien un centre de formation de
formation pour eux personne d'origine
étrangère qui appelle et qui dit est ce
que vous seriez d'accord pour accueillir
des stagiaires
pourquoi pas ils parlent pas français
c'est pas grave on va tenter et ces gens
c'est c'étaient des hommes et des femmes
sont arrivés donc avec leurs difficultés
en langue avec d'autres difficultés
probablement mais en tout cas nous
résidents ces hommes et ces femmes qui
arrivait à la fin de leur vie nous ont
donné une leçon d'humanité et de
tolérance
il y a eu mais des liens mais incroyable
entre eux eux qui venaient d'ailleurs
est eux qui n'avaient pas quitté
quasiment leur commune
il ya eu des échanges très riches
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de partage
beaucoup de rires autour de petites
choses de rien du tout comment on
prépare le thé dans mon pays
comment planter pommes de terre que
celle qui plante pommes de terre comme
nous et puis leur musique leur musique
arabe là qu'est ce qu'elle est belle on
dirait nos gwerz est ce que tu crois
qu'ils vont revenir demain c'était donc
dans cette petite structure
un projet collectif magnifique et il est
là
plusieurs années plus tard retour de
vacances août 2015
une photo la photo du petit et lan trois
ans sur la plage en syrie tout le monde
s'en souvient de cette photo est pour
moi ça a été un choc
qu'est-ce qu'on était en train de fermer
donc moi je ne pouvais pas je ne peux
toujours pas empêcher les guerres
je ne peux pas empêcher la vente des
hommes à des pays dirigés par des
dictateurs
je ne peux pas empêcher le pouvoir de
l'argent qui met à genoux les pays
d'afrique d'asie et d'ailleurs je ne
peux pas empêcher la construction des
murs et des barrières électriques
barbelés et je ne sais quoi je ne peux
pas empêcher les gouvernements de passer
du temps et de gaspiller de l'argent à
inventer des lois pour empêcher l'aide à
ces gens qui viennent d'ailleurs qui ont
connu des choses terribles ces lois là
qui refusent l'autre mémoire à ma porte
je peux faire des choses et bien
évidemment quand la commune de langon a
été choisie pour accueillir les premiers
migrants de calais bien sûr que j'étais
volontaire pour soutenir ce projet bien
sûr j'étais là pour aider cette à cet
accueil
ces jeunes-là qui y arrivait il n'avait
pas beaucoup moins il n'avait pas 25 ans
il avait connu les pires horreurs
il venait d'afghanistan ils étaient
kurdes irakiens dès le départ on a créé
des liens
encore une fois incroyable où ils se
plaignent par heure ils demandent pas
grand chose
simplement voilà des échanges du
quotidien de quoi les rassurer
bon et puis encore quelques mois plus
tard on a su que six mineurs étrangers
étaient mis à la rue le même jour
et là ça a été encore une fois un déclic
6 il fallait trouver les solutions pour
les 6,2 sont allés dans une famille qui
s'est proposé pour un accueil provisoire
deux sont allés dans une colocation où
il y avait quatre jeunes qui leur ont
donné une petite place dans leurs
maisons et les deux autres sont venus
chez nous puis d'autres jeunes ont été
mis à la rue d'autres familles se sont
proposés et encore et encore la première
semaine donc c'était en janvier 2017
là nous sommes en 2019 et nous
continuerons pour bien sûr leur donner
un hébergement mais aussi pour les actes
commis les accompagner dans leurs études
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont venus cette
première semaine a été en tout cas avec
toi et toi qui est devenu à la maison ça
a été d'abord une découverte c'était pas
si facile ni pour eux ni pour nous des
grands moments d'émotion beaucoup de
rires parce qu'en fait ils étaient
soulagés et enfin d'avoir un toit
et puis par exemple un jour dans la
semaine j'ai dit vous avez peut-être du
linge à laver
oui donc j'en avait séché plier une pile
pour un une pile pour l'autre et quand
ils ont vu ça il était
et très étonné et ils vont diminuer
personne ne nous a jamais fait ça les
l'un d'eux ne parlait pas du tout
français est au bout de trois mois
d'accueil comme ça dans les familles
bout de trois mois il me dit dis donc
quand est-ce que tu utilise le mot a
inclus alors je l'inclus parce que
inclus c'est bien le contraire de exclu
oui et puis et puis il ya eu trois jours
là tu es arrivé un soir bien fatigué
c'est vrai où j'étais tout seul on a
mangé ensemble et puis je dis moi
maintenant si tu veux je souhaite
montrer là où tu vas dormir tu te
montrent aussi la somme de mam
voilà ah bah écoutes je j'ai oublié de
prendre une serviette de toilette je
vais vite cherché je reviens j'ai pas
mis trois heures à la nation quand je
suis revenue
il est aimé et combler sur le lit le
bras qui pendaient et il dormait ça
faisait une semaine qu'il était dans la
rue et puis comment dire c'est vrai que
cet accueil c'est c'est pas facile tous
les jours et on se pose plein de
questions
c'est pas facile ni pour eux ni pour
nous puisque nous avons des questions
quelques années notre rôle qu'elle ait
d'autres responsabilités
mais en même temps nous avons tellement
tellement de choses à partager
c'est extraordinaire et puis il ya eu
par exemple aussi l'huile à qui puisqu'à
chaque fois ils s'ils sont dans la rue
c'est parce que leurs papiers ne
correspondent pas aux critères de
l'administration française
donc il faut faire un travail pour eux
chercher les papiers au pays tu sais on
les aide et lui bien il a découvert en
cherchant comme ça la personne qui l'a
élevé il croyait que c'était sa soeur il
savait que ses parents étaient décédés
mais il était persuadé que celle qui l'a
élevé qui lui a payé le voyage qui a
fait là à traverser avec lui pas tout à
fait puisque elle y est restée
il nous a dit voilà elle m'a aidée elle
m'a élevé comme son petit frère
et là je peux même pas pu lui dire au
revoir ni merci et puis et puis c'est
tellement de choses à dire il y à toi
toi qui me dit souvent tu sais moi je
serai une vedette
je serai une star je gagnerai beaucoup
d'argent j'aurais beaucoup de fans
et puis d'ailleurs je t'emmènerai faire
le tour du monde oui donc jeudi à temps
on va un peu baisser les objectifs
je te rappelle que tu es en 1re cat a le
bac de français dans quelques jours donc
voila quoi et il me dit tu sais c'est le
rêve qui m'a fait venir ici alors laisse
mon arrivée
[Applaudissements]